ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne quand loïc
et bien non parce que si on tentant de
dire maintenant c'est à dire qu'ils
attendent depuis déjà avant ça a
commencé à tourner est-ce que s'il vous
plaît dans les commentaires vous pouvez
mettre à quel moment commence la vidéo
ce qui permet vraiment de rater l'intro
et toutes les informations que j'ai à
dire pour contextualiser ce qui fait
qu'après quand les gens regardent la
vidéo et qui savent pas ce que j'ai dit
avant ils comprennent pas ils me disent
dans les commentaires mais je comprends
pas ça en fait la vidéo elle commence
vraiment au moment où elle se lance
voilà c'était mon message engagé du jour
aujourd'hui vous l'avez compris dans le
titre qui n'était pas pu ta clique cette
semaine on va vraiment analyser une
partie de loup garou pour faire ça faut
remonter dans le temps on est dans le
même lieu que la vidéo true story celle
ci loïc ce qui peut la mettre là et la
faire passer par là la faire disparaître
dans une explosion
c'est à dire j'avais loué un théâtre les
gens étaient venus gratuitement je
répète gratuitement parce qu'il y en a
des gens qui m'ont dit mais disons
qu'ils ont payé pour nous voir ça c'est
pas vrai c'est de la merde [ __ ] je
suis rage aujourd'hui mon gars mais je
savais que la chaleur ce que disent et
ce jusqu'à souvent tu lis dans les
commentaires on est déçu par toi
maintenant mais nous aussi des fois on
est déçu on est déçu des commentaires
négatifs non justifiées du comprends ça
mais pas toi c'est toi t'es un vrai
c'est à toi que je m'adressais la javel
ou un théâtre et j'avais fait venir des
abonnés qui voulaient participer à ces
vidéos et donc j'aurais proposé de faire
une partie de loup garou pour l'analyse
et à postériori maintenant il va
forcément y avoir des choses
intéressantes mais il va forcément y
avoir moins de choses que dans une
partie normale et pourquoi je vous le
demande jean jacques sétois louis que je
vais vous le dire tout simplement parce
que les jeux a été un peu intimidé de
monter sur scène
correct devant du public correct s'était
filmé correct j'étais là correct et il
en manque un il en manque un ils se
connaissaient pas entre eux me fout ça
fait quand même des choses qui tronquent
un peu le game on l'a vu la partie à
l'ap a commencé très vite que la partie
s'est lancé personnes
débattez alors que toi et moi on sait
toit de l'autre côté de la caméra qu une
partie de loups-garous commence ça
commence en gueulant quasiment en faites
quoi tout de suite en accusant et en
gueulant un peu moi c'est parti j'écoute
la vidéo commence maintenant pour ce qui
va mettre timecode loïc loric génériques
si il ya le truc de l'analyse avoir van
meter maintenant on va le mettre
maintenant tu sais que ce générique
c'est pareil de la plaque ils le
prennent au premier degré un mode il se
prend vraiment pour un expert en mode
machin est tous sur tous ceux qui me
connaissent pas et qui découvre comme
avec la vidéo sur pascal praud il faut
maintenant plus avec son générique c'est
ridicule il se prend pour qui
en fait ce générique est une blague
depuis le départ et on trouve ça très
drôle ça devient petit peu tu sais comme
le gora fille en fait à des gens qui
prennent les articles 1er degré oil et
loïc ce qui peut tuer corrèze
[Musique]
la nuit est tombée et tout le monde a
les yeux fermés néanmoins néanmoins les
loups garous se réveille
loïc au montage ne met pas tout de suite
ce plan là où les loups garous se
réveille ça va être plus intéressant
pour qu'ils puissent eux de l'autre côté
de l'image voir est ce que tu pourrais
me ramener la fin de mes phrases je les
ai laissés dans la réserve
merci et la voyante se réveille elle se
réveille et elle me montre l'identité
l'identité de cette personne
de plus c'était tellement énorme mais en
fait ça montre le stress qu'ils avaient
jeudi l'identité de cette personne et la
sorcière fait ouais voilà la voyante ah
oui c'était la voyante oui en fait oui
voilà donc ben oui forcément tout le
monde à partir de ce moment là c'est qui
est la vôtre
je pense qu'il a l'habitude de jouer et
je pense que vraiment il ne ferait
jamais cette erreur s'ils savaient pas
été un peu stressante d'ailleurs c'est
moi qui mène le jeu c'est filmé il ya du
public tu joues avec des gens que tu
connais pas bon ils sont pas encore sur
leurs appuis on va aller vite un peu
plus loin quand même
vous êtes tous rayonnant tout ce beau
sauf toi qui a décidé cette nuit au
tessin par un de voir cette image là
précisément saül qu'à un tout petit peu
avant et sert le cas là je viens de
faire une blague pour annoncer le décès
de la personne parce qu'aujourd'hui je
parle à lui que par manque plus que vous
et là tout le monde le regarde on voit
ici directement dans les yeux dans les
yeux lui dans les yeux lui dans les yeux
lui dans les yeux lui dans les yeux ce
qu'une personne qui n'arrive pas à
supporter son regard qui met la main
devant sa bouche en synergologie
attention la synergologie est à prendre
avec des pincettes et jora énorme mais
on dit que c'est pour s'empêcher de dire
quelque chose qu'on a un secret et en
plus ce qu'est la tête un peu baissé
symbole de la honte c'est lui et lui
effectivement et loups garous et on voit
vraiment sa différence d'attitude avec
tous les autres est en fait dans ce jeu
c'est ça quand on joue surtout avec des
gens qu'on connaît pas dès qu'on a une
réaction spontanée je veux dire il faut
pas sauter dessus il faut pas se laisser
imprégner quand je dis que lui est mort
on n'a pas besoin d'aller voir cette
information visionnement c'est pas très
important parce que il est mort de toute
manière ça n'apporte rien au jeu par
contre c'est à ce moment là où il faut
mater tout le monde et voir quelle est
la réaction des autres vis-à-vis de ça
une bonne partie brave certainement vous
dire un truc moi quand je suis parti de
loup garou avec un groupe de potes je ne
passe pas plus d'une nuit d'hier que où
je me fais tuer durant la nuit ou au
réveil de toute manière on me but voilà
et je ne peux rien dire si je dis rien
c'est louche si je dis un truc c'est
lusti j'argumente c'est louche basket
chaque pompe ouais mais il est encore de
faire du mentalist est en fait je suis
toujours mort au final vous a demandé à
l'envoyeur
[Musique]
vas-y donner ton avis mais je ne sais
pas et tout ça je suis pas loin
alors attention évidemment je sais que
vous allez le remarquer que vous allez
tous en parler si je n'en parle pas
cette personne là un tic nerveux au
niveau de l'oeil droit
donc c'est quelque chose qui ne veut
rien dire sur le fait qu'ils soient
loups garous ou pas c'est quelque chose
qui doit avoir
je pense depuis la naissance et ce type
doit s'amplifier avec le stress a
toujours cette main qui revient de la
bande à la bouche en permanence sa
chaussure vous j'avais le choix je suis
village où lui vient de se faire une
conclusion qui est très intéressante
mais on a un qui a dit écoute voilà
comme on sait qui est la voyante
puisqu'elle s'est trahi pourtant lui
demande et donc la voyante et interprété
par là qu'on voit pas de danse libre
voilà moi l'info que j'ai obtenu c'est
que lui en l'occurrence et villageois là
il ya cette personne qui a fait un ouais
mais pourquoi voulez savoir qui est la
voyante et tout ça passe à la somme
ondimba en fait tout le monde sait c'est
même lui qui disait tout le monde sait
qui elle a boy en tête et donc il y le
villageois
ça avance un petit peu dans le discours
et là on passe à un début de vote et
elle dit ben moi je vote contre lui
tient et en fait juste lui a le bon
raisonnement à ce moment là et puis mais
pourquoi tu votes contre moi et bien de
dire j'étais villageois a fait ouais
mais il est peut-être complice est en
fait il peut pas être complices puisque
toute manière on sait que c'est la
voyante puisque tout le monde a détecté
c'était la voyante donc forcément la
voyante à 10 da fresh chose puisqu'elle
veut gagner avec les villageois donc son
agressivité envers lui est vraiment d'un
illogisme pur
sauf si elle s'était détaché en disant
ah oui excuse j'ai pas suivi je suis
bête et a dit non mais on sait jamais
peut-être que tes complices en fait elle
s'enfonce là dessus et lui vient juste
de dire sauf si toi tu es loup garou
évidemment et bien c'était une bête
conclu
car évidemment aller le garou donc voilà
on a un profil de loups garous qui et
c'est comme ça de placer une agression
sur quelqu'un on à lui on le sait qui
est très en autres étaient très discrets
mais c'est pas le seul est très en
retrait est très discret alors lui a
commencé à participer mais c'est assez
récent et il ya deux filles de l'autre
côté qui dont trois filles même qui
n'ont pas du tout participé pour le
moment et ça malheureusement on ne peut
pas l'analyse est vraiment vraiment
vraiment très bien puisque encore une
fois il ya le stress le fait qu'ils se
connaissent pas et c est pourquoi l je
sais pas demandez de choisir la moins en
temps normal si on n'était pas dans une
partie aussi spécial je trouverais juste
un truc louche c'est à dire que elles se
défendent pas être loup garou elle se
défend vivement et on voit une forme de
sincérité
en l'occurrence elle ne l'est pas mais
par contre elle elle laisse sa aprt un
stand by
elle propose pas d'alternative en
général quand accuse à tort dit nina là
c'est pas moi bon écoute voilà dans les
réactions moi j'ai plutôt des doutes sur
untel ou sur intel sa relance pas le jeu
mais c'est encore une fois le début de
partie le jeu est assez l'endroit où
étaient cachés
là on a des personnes qu'on pas trop
partie b elle a participé à un petit peu
elle pas encore elle pas vraiment non
plus il ya encore une personne qu'on n'a
pas entendu du tout mais qu un profil
relativement timide je trouve j'ai
entendu de nous intimider c'est à dire
toi et toi c'est tout comme ton prénom
coralie et espère hockey lever la main
ceux qui veulent tuer corey donc là
j'arrive à en mettre du tout en posant
une décision ferme pour que ça avance en
fait là on l'appelle but mais lui a levé
la main un tout petit peu plus tard que
les autres parce que en réalité vous
savez ce qui se passe dans sa tête il a
depuis tout à l'heure ils essayent de
faire profil bas et de s'intégrer au
groupe
qui du coup est un peu étrange parce
qu'il ya quand même trois personnes qui
ne votent pas pour l'instant c'est de la
même dans quatre personnes lui s'il vote
je crois donc ces deux là et la jeune
fille qui est ici qu'on n'a pas vraiment
entendu sauf que lui on sait que c'est
le voyant on n'y a pas de problème mais
je trouve que ça pose la question sur
lequel de ces deux personnes seraient
potentiellement loup garou sachant que
rappelez vous il nous manque un loup
garou là encore coup dur en est là elle
se dit je peux pas être la seule à pas
voter elle commence à lever la main elle
ne les regardent même pas elle va
essayer de s'insérer dans le groupe tu
meurs là c'est pareil quand on fait
l'annoncent du look vers vous ne
regardez pas la personne
regardez toutes les autres qui baissent
les yeux qui commence à avoir un symbole
de monde pendant que toutes les autres
personnes se réjouissent réellement
d'avoir tué un loup garou n'ya qu'une
personne là à l'image qu'on voit dans
cette position encore une fois et c'est
elle et c'est le loup garou
le troisième larron qui mérite de mourir
qui montre la voyante qui ne me semblent
vous pouvez vous rendormir
la voyante se réveille cette personne là
c'est alors personne voilà c'est tout à
fait logique que la voyante désigne
cette personne parce qu'on l'a pas
entendu parler depuis le départ c'est
quand même très suspect et en même temps
se dit est-ce que cette personne est
timide ou pas c'est pour ça qu'ils
cherchent à contrôler c'est plutôt bien
joué de la part de la voyante pas et là
je lui fais un signe comme ça ça veut
dire que c'est un villageois
et puis la sorcière se réveille aux
sorcières
sortir dormez bien les regarder c'est
pas beau ne sait pas bien joué la force
et se réveille et elle a tellement bougé
que aide à bouger la tête parce qu'elle
a dû sentir tous ces mouvements elle
sorcières une personne a été tuée cette
nuit
est ce qu'elles méritent de recevoir une
potion pour revivre est ce qu'une
personne mérite de recevant la potion
pour décider de placer sa décide de le
tuer lui parce qu'on l'a pas trop
entendu imagine mais vraiment je trouve
qu'il a été tué comme ça gratos à une
personne décédée cette nuit universelle
en la personne de me disent bonjour je
vous fais voir on a toujours la même
chose il ya qu une personne qui regarde
au sol et qui baisse la tête basse et la
personne qui la tue à tort la sorcière
et on les loups garous s'il avait été
attentifs à ça aurait pu il avait
vraiment un créneau pour savoir qui
était la sorcière quoi la sorcière tu as
tort un villageois
donc elle joue contre sa propre équipe à
ce moment là c'est le moment où des
loups garous peuvent savoir qui et les
sorcières je vous laisse débattre
qu'est-ce qu'on élimine alors là c'est
très particulier pour ceux qui
connaissent pas bien le loup garou
c'est à dire que là tu peux avoir
l'impression que les loups garous ont
tués en dix durant la nuit mais en fait
c'est plus complexe que ça les loups
garous ont voulu étudier la voyante la
sorcière a sauvé la voyante et à tuer en
dit ce qui fait que les loups garous
restants ne savent pas exactement ce qui
s'est passé sur le coup ils ont un petit
bug aussi mais c'est pourquoi il aurait
été très intéressant que la sorcière
plutôt que d'éprouver de la honte
cherche tout de suite qui avait de la
compréhension dans leur regard on a vu
elle qu'elle avait un vrai truc
d'enseignés de what the fuck gilles n'a
pas voté pour tuer des gens ouais il
très malin il demande qui n'avaient pas
voté pour tuer la personne précédente
lors du dernier vote et c'est
intéressant parce que la dernière
personne c'était un loup garou
donc il chercha soir qui n'a pas voté
par contre je pense que sa conclusion va
est erroné on va le voir tout de suite
c'est à dire que on le sait les loups
garous au fur et à mesure vont
s'intégrer au vote et on l'a vu comment
lui a mis ça m'a juste après et puis
d'autres personnes aussi dans tout
dernier en mode tu vois donc en fait
c'est qu'ils n'avaient pas voté au
départ pour rester parce qu'après s'est
passé réellement significatif les autres
sauf que leurs votes vont rien changer
donc il s'intègre au vote
est ce que j'avais très mal à personne a
demandé si la voyante avait vu quelque
chose le loup garou qui a été très
discret depuis tout à l'heure
relance le jeu mais ces malades sa part
parce qu'il prend une position une
position neutre qui n'engagent en rien
ouais de mosellans sur blue était
dangereuse pourquoi il est anormal que
la sortie en poche
là ils comprennent ce qui s'est passé
elle elle a sûrement l'habitude de jeu
passe quasi mais pourquoi la voyante est
pas morte parce que la voyante et
dangereuse pour les loups garous bas
effectivement il avait voulu la tuer au
départ je suis seule la deuxième
personne qui tout à l'heure a défendu
les premiers aux gares ou d'être aussi
loin que ça reste un souci du kodokan
est soupçonné et l'a conduit dans sa
défense quand vous êtes villageois ça
c'est un vrai conseil ne prenez pas une
accusation comme un truc ah ouais ben
vas-y tu moi comme ça on va perdre
prenez le vraiment en mode non on est
dans la même team donné des arguments
tout de suite parce que moi quand je
fais des partis si la personne que
j'accuse elle le prend par lego à vous
aurez baisse fais ce que tu veux je me
dis ok là se défend pas donc ouais je
vais la tuer tu vois servez votre propre
équipe n'oubliez pas de quelle équipe
vous faites partie fait si chaud les
amis parce que celui-là
c'est un bouton d'abonnement en fait
c'est vraiment comme ça vous pouvez vous
abonner ce n'est pas encore le cas la
vidéo et c'est une punition envers la
blague de loïc parce que c'est lui qui
va le faire bouger comme ça en post prod
afin de prendre énormément de temps pour
réfléchir à la qualité de ses blagues
j'ai pas défendu c'est juste que j'avais
aucun argument pour voter contre elle
donc j'avais pas de raison de ziggy
contre elle c'est tout j'ai donné aucun
autre vous donc
et ça c'est intéressant ce qu'elle dit
voilà elle commence à argumenter une
vraie défense lit non j'ai pas voté
contre elle parce que j'avais pas
d'arguments contre elle mais j'ai donné
aucun autre nom et c'est vrai que dans
une positionnement de loups garous tu
aurais tendance quand même à déporter
sur quelqu'un est là c'est marrant donc
là du coup elle va déporter les soupçons
sur quelqu'un d'autre mais parce que
j'aime la force elle faire un bon rythme
et le jeu et elle dit bah y'en a qu'on
atteint pas beaucoup genre toi pourquoi
lui plutôt que les personnes autour
d'elle parce que quand tu as
visuellement quelqu'un tu vois mieux ses
réactions et on va voir s'il se
travaille ou pas en tout cas son sourire
est bien présent et gonon martin tout le
stress
il a des rythmes de petits mouvements
corporels qu'il n'avait pas du tout tout
à l'heure il a déjà des critiques deux
fois la alliés est ce que tu es loup
garou
non pas vraiment
pire réponse du mot j'espère que j'ai
encore rétréci j'ai croatie énorme l'oif
il a dit parce que tu es lougarot il a
dit non pas vraiment pas vraiment ça ne
veut rien dire du tout en fait ou tu dis
non ou tu dis non mais tu peux pas dire
non pas vraiment et le pas vraiment ces
dates révision ultime évidemment
énormément de joueurs l'ont perçu ça
dépend des noms mais je pense qu'il faut
se fier à l'instant de la voyante plus
ce que j'aurais pu voir les cartes en
même temps ils me comprennent les
villageois temps traînée par les cheveux
jusqu'à l'échafaud tué parce que tu
étais ville ils ont tué l'une d'entre
elles et là encore c'est le moment de
regarder les joueurs ce qui se passe
c'est très intéressant à ce moment là
l'étonnement soulagement ultime
là on a un tout petit derrière moi mais
c'est fou quand même il ya un espèce de
black out dans son regard
lui il regrette complètement il était
complètement sûr de ce qu'il avait fait
donc s'il est dans le regret c'est que
ça l'embêtent que ce une villageoise qui
est morte lui pareille est dégoûté et
voilà il est dégoûté il est dégoûté
qu'elle soit morte la lui aussi c'était
de là il ya que lui qui a un visage
neutre à ce moment là mesdames et
messieurs la lui retombe car c'est qu'on
lui sait observer qui change de tête
ambiant merde il faut que notre
expression visage c'est énorme
les loups tard vous se réveille et
désigne une personne qui mérite de
mourir
les loups garous se rendort et donc si
la dernière fois que je te réveillant un
peu trop et puis tout le monde se rue
le monde non la voyante petit problème
mais j'ai pas d'arguments fondamentale
dire non je ne le supporte pas beaucoup
je suis villageoise et je confirme
caroline nous terminons mais j'hésite
entre les deux larrons face kline qui
par mon coup les candidats dont je suis
plutôt suiveurs du nageur de traîne de
seuils et récupère la jolie forêt le duo
se réveille et me désigne quelqu'un bon
show car on a un décès les étoiles décès
et donc la voyante avait habitué des
villageois merci beaucoup des batteries
8/4 suisse martin et bouddha pour faire
le souffle
elle ne serait pas nos gardes ma
priorité à ce que google ou à voter pour
elle donc techniquement il n'a pas boudé
pendant les gens qu'est ce qui vous fait
dire à vancouver voilà vous êtes là
c'est pas mal avant comme lui se sent en
danger il a laissé des consignes ses
consignes s'avère une bonne villageois
une sorcière et potentiellement mais là
la manière dont il a dit qu'il était
obligé de la joie du coup aller on a
tous les signes de sincérité
c'est sûr pour mais moi je pense plutôt
que c'est toi toi même c'est marrant
parce que vous remarquerez aussi dans
vos parties de loups garous ce qu'on
vient de voir sur elle quand sur les fin
de partie surtout on accuse d'être le
loup garou le loup garou a toujours
tendance à chercher une expression qui
semblerait être la bonne à voir dans ce
genre d'accusation et tu ne sais pas
laquelle ces et réfléchissez y
si on vous accuse comment vous allez
réagir quelles expressions de visage tu
vas faire voir et bien tu sais pas parce
que justement c'est spontané en
thermales dont qui la cache derrière un
essai d'explosion a retrouvé plusieurs
fois dans la vidéo et combien juste de
retrouver encore une fois juste avant
sur elle qui est il coûte il faut que
j'aie une expression et je pense que
c'est bien de faire ça mais on sait que
ça correspond à rien et puisqu'on à une
personne qui décide volontairement
d'avoir une expression qui répond à rien
c'est ultra louche et là c'est dommage
on lit je dis est ce que tu auras
accuser quelqu'un et donc elle renvoie
vers l'autre qui est a priori par ou de
loups-garous et en tout cas tout le
monde le considère un peu comme le lead
à ce moment là si vous êtes loup garou
il ya un battle entre deux personnes
ray accuse tout de suite l'autre
personne contre qui tu es en battle est
fortement de moi c'est elle c'est
évident en fait je suis d'accord avec
untel untel et untel qui ont soumis son
nom
rangez vous de l'autre bord belhadj
les personnes qui accusent baptiste
lever la main les personnes qui accusent
lauriane s'intéresse à vos arguments
il faut des arguments qu'est ce que tu
as fait pour nous aider dans la partie
qui arrive qu'est ce que tu as fait pour
nous aider dans la partie pour savoir
qui est qui les personnes qui a qui se
bâtissent une deux trois toujours les
personnes qui accusent lauriane de 3,4
lauriane servier c'est pas mal ça
manière alors lui a demandé à lui les
arguments mais lui je pense c'est ça son
discours c'est très intelligent
en termes de stratégie de jeu il s'est
dit je n'arriverai jamais à les
convaincre sa part est toujours luz
qu'on donne beaucoup d'argumentation du
coup je vais moi demander à elle
directement et c'est ça mon argument qu
est ce que toi tu as fait pour nous
aider durant la partie parce qu'en
disant ça tout le monde à se rappeler
que lui il a beaucoup aidé à tuer les
loups garous au final et quelle bête pas
tant que ça et c'était une bonne
stratégie
je trouvais ça intéressant d'analyser
une partie de loups garous parce que ça
donne des conseils qu'on voit ce qu'on
peut y voir où il nous manque juste un
tout petit peu de matière du fait que ce
soit des personnes qui se connaissent
pas qu'on va forcément l'habitude de
jouer ni d'être filmé du coup pour la
partie 2 je vous propose à vous si vous
avez un groupe de joueurs avec qui vous
avez l'habitude de jouer au loup garou
de me contacter pour ça ça va être très
simple je vais mettre dans les jours qui
viennent un petit formulaire en story
sur instagram donc suivez moi sur cette
install g
ok donc vous me suivez sur instagram
vous suivez le jour où josh le
formulaire vous vous inscrivez il faut
qu'il y ait quand même pas mal de
joueurs que vous ayez l'habitude de
jouer au loup garou l'habitude de jouer
ensemble si possible et nous on viendra
on montera plus de caméras que ça ok on
retrouvera un lieu on mettra plus
d'angles de caméra pourquoi pas
peut-être si on est du budget de prendre
ingo propre à personne pour les films et
de prêt enfin on trouvera ça ça sera pas
tout de suite sûrement à la rentrée ce
serait cool si vous êtes d'accord avec
ça dit dans dit je suis d'accord je suis
d'accord minitel ok dit je suis d'accord
minitel dans les commentaires faut que
tu l'auras écrivain dossier lacan jamais
vu un minitel ici j'espère que ça vous a
plu si c'est le cas vous laïque et la
vidéo comme d'habitude vous pouvez vous
abonner il
vous avez la vidéo de la semaine
dernière ici vous avez une autre vidéo
si vous avez ma chaîne secondaire qu'est
ce que j'ai dit qu'elle est arrivée cet
été loïc ici du loup aura très bientôt
de chat